on the one-year commemoration of george
floyd's death more black people are
dying and not at the hands of the cops
the broader racial reckoning
continues with propagandistic efforts to
tear down america's institutions
and the new york times notices that
democrats aren't very loud about the
border anymore
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like big tech and the government
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first let me remind you that in
april alone consumer prices increased by
4.2
it's the highest bump since 2008. higher
fuel prices and higher food prices
construction cost housing prices like
inflation is really hitting
it's hitting so much that a columnist
for the new york times trying to
downplay the inflation he's like were
the 1970s that bad
yes they were that bad and one way that
you can hedge against inflation and
uncertainty
is of course by investing in precious
metals so i'm going to tell you again
if you haven't yet reached out to birch
gold to diversify part of your ira or
401k into a precious metals ira
today is a great day to do it text ben
to 47 47 47
get a free information kit i'm
protecting your savings with gold i buy
my gold from birch gold they have an a
plus rating with the better business
bureau countless five star reviews
over ten thousand happy customers talk
to them have them help you
safeguard your investments again gold
has always been an
asset that is not worth zero and it has
been your hedge against the government
inflating
the currency tex benz 474747 when you
make a purchase before june 30th birch
gold will send you a signed copy of my
book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps for free
while supplies last again text ben to
474747 protect your savings
today and once again when you make a
purchase before june 30th to get a free
copy of my last book how to destroy
america in three
easy steps signed by moa go check it out
right now tech spend 247 47 47
to get started alrighty so this week
marks the one year commemoration
of the death now legally adjudicated
murder
of george floyd and the media are
awash in self-referential glory
they they keep talking about how
wonderful they are how they have made
the world a better place through their
attention
on the racial reckoning now there's only
one problem nothing has gotten better in
the last gen race zero things
in fact black lives matter has done an
awful lot of harm to the black community
to the united states at large now with
regard to what's going on in the middle
east international politics the black
lives matter movement has been a
terrible thing
for the united states not because of
attention paid
to police malfeasance and misconduct and
brutality all of that's fine but because
the broader black lives
matter agenda has very little to do with
protecting black lives
and a lot to do with the structures of
the united states and the structures of
the west
and tearing those down and the practical
ramifications of tearing down the
structures means more dead black people
that is just the way
that reality works unfortunately in the
real world
okay so the new york times commemorates
the one year anniversary
of george floyd's death with an article
titled on the ashes of tragedy mixed
emotions on anniversary of george
floyd's death
the crowds that gathered in minneapolis
and elsewhere reflected on what has
changed and what has not in america
since mr floyd was murdered by a police
officer it was a day of reflection
of remembrance a time to lay flowers and
say prayers to celebrate black culture
with art and music and food and to
recall the life of a man whose death one
year ago shook the country and forced it
to confront its painful legacy of racism
and police brutality now what's amazing
about that of course is that there was
not a single iota of evidence that was
ever brought to show that derek chovan
murdered george floyd
based on racial resentment not in iota
it was never even claimed in court
and yet it became the cause of this
broader re-examination of just how
terrible and racist
america is and when the new york times
says that they examined the life of
george floyd well they really didn't
because you examined the life of george
floyd it might lead you to some opposite
conclusions about the value
of policing after all george floyd
before his tragic and untimely death
had committed a bevy of crimes for which
he was correctly arrested
in minneapolis on tuesday as people
gathered to mark the anniversary of the
police killing of george floyd there was
space for it all the trauma and the
grief says the new york times
some celebration over a murder
conviction of a police officer and a
measure of hope too that in death mr
floyd a black man had nudged america
toward more racial equality now here's
the thing
nope the reality is that more black
people died this year
as a result of the black lives matter
movement completely cuddling
the police into not doing their jobs the
black lives matter movement
which has fought very hard against the
systematic
institutions of the united states
declaring them all racist
at root has made racial polarization in
the country significantly worse
new poll out today from the economist
shows
that only 11 of americans believe that
relations between minorities and police
since george floyd's death are better
one in 10. fully 38 percent of americans
believe that relations between
minorities and the police since floyd's
death are worse
okay so four times as many americans
believe that things got worse then got
better with regard to relations between
the cops
and the black community in the united
states
but the the media are going to continue
to celebrate this stuff even though the
ramifications of what black lives
matter i know we're supposed to just
ignore the two billion dollars in
property damage
and the skyrocketing murder rate in all
of america's major cities
i know we're supposed to ignore all of
that because we're supposed to pretend
that if you yell at the cops enough then
magically
all inequality is erased but that is not
the way things work
in fact you have exacerbated many of the
underlying conditions that lead
to less investment in high crime areas
in low-income
areas you have exacerbated many of the
conditions that lead to bad
relationships between the police
and local populations nonetheless the
media are just
they're cheering themselves because they
spent the last year investing in the
narrative that george floyd's death was
a referendum
on what the united states means more
broadly and that george floyd's death
because it was racist without actually
being racist
that is america as a whole even as all
eyes were on minneapolis says the new
york times where the governor issued a
proclamation for a moment of silence
lasting nine minutes and 29 seconds
the amount of time a white officer's
need remained on mr floyd's neck people
gathered in remembrance all across the
country to honor not just the life of mr
floyd but to reflect on what has changed
in what has not in america again
this was not honoring the life of floyd
i mean it was really honoring the death
of floyd to be fair
in his commemoration of his death not
anything that he did during his life and
that is an important distinction because
if you believe that floyd's death was a
transformative moment that's because you
believe
that the real problem in america is the
cops writ broadly
right again not a shred of evidence was
provided for the for the idea that derek
chovin the cop in the george floyd
murder
was actually a racist or did this out of
racial animus
nonetheless the new york times has
demonstrators marched in downtown los
angeles philadelphia officials
planned a citywide prayer vigil
protesters in chicago gathered to call
for police reform and mr floyd's
daughter gianna was invited to appear at
an atlanta rally titled my daddy
changed the world all this was happening
as members of the floyd family met
privately with president biden and vice
president kamala harris at the white
house
afterward the white house issued a
statement in which biden said that while
it has been a year since mr floyd's
death the first year can still feel like
they got the news
a few seconds ago okay so
number one important to note that when
the governor of minneapolis or
minnesota rather is calling for a moment
of silence lasting for nine minutes and
29 seconds
i've noticed zero moments of silence for
the vast bevy of black people
who have been murdered over the last
year
not by cops i've noticed that and that
by the way is statistically
significantly more indicative
of how many black derek chovin peop
which is a statistical anomaly is an act
of brutality and also a statistical
anomaly
okay but the media again they have to
push forward this myth that the black
lives matter movement has been good for
america that there's been this quote
unquote racial reckoning and you see
that word everywhere a reckoning
reckoning for whom
for whom like what is the reckoning
designed to do
blm knows what it's designed to do tear
down the institutions but the media just
keeps saying racial reckoning and what
they mean by this is
the entire left-wing agenda must be
adopted wholesale because we have used
george floyd's death as a lever to pry
open all of those institutions and then
gut them
the word reckoning suggests that
somebody has to be reckoned what has to
be reckoned with
if we're saying that american history
has to be looked at and that we have to
see the impact of american history on
the present
i agree we should always do that but
then you have to look at inequality
today how much of that is caused by
history and how much of that is caused
by personal decision making
if you're really going to fix people's
problems you can talk about history as
much as you want but if you're talking
about problems like the crime rate in
black communities or the murder rate in
black communities
and you say well that's the legacy of
slavery or jim crow
even if you grant that premise which is
dubious even if you grant
that premise you'd have to say the only
way to stop that is for people to stop
killing people
talking about slavery and jim crow
doesn't stop people from killing each
other
the same thing is true of the single
motherhood rate in the black community
if you actually want to solve the
problem
and create greater equality of outcome
you need people to take different
actions
talking about the racist history of the
united states doesn't cause
a man to now stick around after knocking
up a woman
personal decision making has to change
if you actually wish to effectuate
different outcomes but blm is not
interested
in individual actions they explicitly
say this the entire blm movement is
predicated on the idea that you don't
have individual agency that you can't
make your life better that black
americans aren't capable of making their
lives better
strangely there's a pretty hardcore
bigotry
of low expectations you're a bigotry of
no expectations here with regards to the
left
you can't expect black americans to act
individually
in in good citizen fashion because of
the legacy of racism
but we here we white liberals we can
correct all of the ills of american
society because we are responsible and
we do have unbelievable levels of agency
this is the arrogance of this sort of
robin d'angelo white fragility model in
which white liberals are responsible
for a utopian fixing of the united
states
and black americans have no
responsibility whatsoever in their
individual lives to take actions that
better their lives
because to even imply that would suggest
that the systems in which we live ought
to stand
and we'll get to what the actual impact
of all this has been in the united
states
and the answer is nothing good for black
americans
again where's the positive outcome i'm
waiting for it i haven't seen any of it
really for black americans what is
better now today than it was one year
ago
is there anything we'll get to that in
one second first
let's talk about the fact that it's hard
to keep an eye on your house all day
especially if you're not home
all day but i often want to check in on
my house make sure that my
baby is doing well make sure that i know
who's stopping by the front door and
dropping off packages
this is why i rely on ring if somebody
stops by or something is going on
outdoors around my home
ring lets me know it's peace of mind any
time knowing that our home is protected
at my house i can keep an eye on every
corner of our house with rings easy to
install indoor and outdoor cams to get
ring alarm for yourself go to ring.com
ben it's the perfect way to start your
ring experience the best thing i enjoy
besides ring being a powerful asset for
my home ring is also super affordable
it's a whole home security system you
can easily install yourself
it's never been more important to see
what's going on at your house now is a
great time to make a ring happen when we
moved cross country my wife said
get the ring devices on the house we did
it like within the very first week of
moving
it's great to know you're not gonna miss
a visitor with rings hassle-free easy to
install indoor and outdoor cams
know when the packages are delivered and
also allows me to keep an eye on my wild
children start protecting your home
today with ring alarm go to ring.com
ben get your ring alarm security kit
today you can build the system that's
right for your home have it up and
running in minutes that's ring.com once
more
ring.com okay so the propaganda efforts
that are put out by the media here that
all of america's institutions need to be
completely overthrown just in line with
what democrats have always wanted to do
apparently
this propaganda effort is being put
forward with with a special
sort of fervor this week so al sharpton
and bill de blasio knelt for george
floyd yesterday al sharpton
the idea that you're going to make race
relations in america better by going to
al sharpton one of the great racial
conflagrationists of the last
half-century is utterly insane
it's it's bizarre this is a guy who was
involved in the incitement of at least
two racial riots and a liar on a wide
variety of other issues including the
tawana bradley case
and yet there he is with the mayor of
new york kneeling for george floyd
presumably to make race relations better
in some way this from the same mayor who
hamstrung the police while people
ran around manhattan breaking into
stores last summer
george floyd's murder
energized and ignited a movement
all over the globe we want to see the
george floyd
justice and policing act passed by the
congress
when we saw a movement like this in the
60s
it led to the civil rights act of 64.
okay um so this is what they're looking
for what they're looking for is a
complete overthrow of certain
legislative areas of american life so
important to note that the 1964 civil
rights act which did a lot of very good
things
also completely shifted the relationship
between between the government and the
individual
for example it completely did away with
freedom of association
it actually extended into the private
sphere in some pretty negative ways with
with long-term externalities christopher
caldwell discusses this
in his book the age of entitlement it's
the it's
it was really a um a ground shift
in how america saw the role of
government
well this is what democrats are seeking
now is another ground shift in the role
of government
so the floyd family met with the the
team at the white house yesterday and
then emerged to say that we need more
laws protecting black americans which is
weird because we do have laws protecting
black americans they're called the laws
we're just thankful for what's going on
and we just want this charge for our
policing act to be passed in the future
is there any questions
because this is the thing if you can
make
federal laws to protect the bird which
is the bald eagle
you can make federal laws to protect
people of color
okay there are federal laws protecting
people of color it's called the 1964
civil rights act
it's also a bevy of other pieces of
legislation that protect black people
in the united states which is why the
number of black people who are killed
unarmed by the cops every year is
usually
fewer than 20. okay not only that we've
had ground shifts
in the treatment of discrimination in
american life like on a private level
discrimination against black people is
considered the worst thing that you can
do in america
and i think in many ways properly so
there's broad agreements on this and yet
none of that apparently makes a
difference we are back in the 60s it's
the exact same thing as it was in 1960
when we were emerging from actual legal
legally mandated discrimination in the
south meanwhile joe biden was being all
weird so he met with george floyd's
daughter
and uh he he got strange because this is
what our daughter
president does first thing today
gave me a big hug and uh
we spent uh she also uh
loved the idea that she said i'm really
hungry
and so he said you're having
snacks what is he even rambling about
he's round around
how george floyd's daughter wanted
snacks or something okay so what is the
biden administration doing
well according to foxnews.com the
department of state under president
biden issued guidance to all diplomatic
and consular posts
encouraging officials of support
official displays of support
for black lives matter on the one year
anniversary of george floyd's murder on
may 25th and beyond
according to a leaked memo for an
anonymous state department source the
department wrote that it
supports the use of the term black lives
matter in messaging content
as well as in speeches and foreign
diplomatic engagements on may 25th and
beyond the memo allows us diplomats to
fly the black lives matter flag
outside of embassies it's a first of all
this crap has to stop okay the only flag
that ought to be flying outside the
american embassy
is the american flag okay that is the
only flag that we all agree on in the
united states the black lives matter
flag
which is a very rich it is a very
polarizing flag not because
again black lives don't matter the term
black lives matter is a semantically
overloaded term as i've explained many
times before
of course black lives matter on a pure
level black lives matter the same as
every other life in the united states
matter
it's black white or green we all agree
with that but black lives matter
semantically overloaded because of
course what people really mean when they
say black lives matter is that black
people are specifically targeted in the
united states by the authorities that is
not true
and then there is the argument that all
inequality is the result of
discrimination
which is similarly untrue so when you
fly the black lives matter flag what
you're really doing
is imbibing that message and then saying
that that is the message of america
which of course it is not
in fact it runs directly counter to the
messages of the constitution of the
united states and the declaration of
independence
we've seen the the use of of flags that
are not the american flag at embassies
and i object to all of them
we should not be flying gay pride flags
or transgender pride flags or blm flags
or christian flags outside the american
embassy we have a flag it's called the
american flag that's the only one that
should be flying outside of american
embassies
in any case the memo acts as an
authorization for agency higher-ups to
display the blm flag
on the external facing flagpole to any
chiefs of submission who determines such
a display is appropriate in light of
local conditions
anthony blinken has also previously
authorized embassy to fly the lgbtq
pride flag from may 17th
through the end of june in recognition
of pride month celebrations again the
the overt politicization
of what should be a political things in
american life like the american flag
is pretty incredible okay so what has
been the actual impact of blm
has there been a grand impact to blm has
the racial reckoning
been good for black americans or all
americans we'll get to that in just one
second first
let's talk about a simple fact your
sleep quality these days
might be disturbed for a variety of
reasons my baby daughter has been
getting me up at 5
30 in the morning i'm very tired but
that means that when i lie down at night
put my head on that pillow
i need to be sleeping on a mattress that
is super comfortable and made just for
me this is where helix sleep comes in
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattress is great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for
plus-sized folks so if you're looking
for a mattress you take the quiz you
order the mattress you're matched to the
mattress comes right to your doorship
for free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix is awarded the
number one best mattress pick
of 2020 by gq and wired magazine just
head on over to helixsleep.com take that
two minute sleep quiz you'll get the
best mattress of your life
10-year warranty try it out for a
hundred nights risk free they'll pick it
up for you if you don't love it you got
nothing to lose
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders two free pillows for
our listeners at hewixsleep.com that's a
fantastic deal helix sleep dot com
slash bending up to 200 bucks off your
mattress order and two free pillows
for our listeners okay so have things
gotten better over the course of the
last year
the answer of course is no they've
gotten significantly worse at the end of
chicago police reported more than 750
murders a jump of more than 50 percent
by mid-december l.a saw a 30 increase
over the previous year with 322
homicides there were 437 homicides in
new york city
by december 20th nearly 40 more than the
previous year
so yes things are getting worse they're
getting significantly worse
i mean just back in late march the new
york times ran a piece
and that remember today the new york
times runs a piece about the the
wonderful
events that are taking place all across
america to commemorate the death of
george floyd
and america's racial reckoning and all
of this well you know what's happening
at george floyd square
people getting shot at george floyd
square like literally yesterday
literally yesterday okay here is tape of
an ap reporter
reporting from outside the george
memorial at this square in minneapolis
where george floyd died
and gunfire breaks out yesterday
so how about that racial reckoning game
yeah
is is this making lives better friend
here we go
this bill of comprehensive police reform
uh
to be uh just got to be careful here
with some gunshots excuse us
oh excuse us sorry so just some gunfire
breaking out here at george floyd
memorial and in the george blade square
i mean
no biggie and of course the answer is it
is no biggie because this happens like
every weekend at the george floyd square
hey how many shots are being fired here
it's like a war zone over here
and where are the cops the cops of
course have been blocked off from this
area is the answer
this place has become utterly lawless
according to npr at least one person was
shot tuesday near the minneapolis
intersection
where george floyd was murdered by
police one year ago an event that set
off international protests over racial
justice
minneapolis police said they responded
just after 10 am to reports of shots
fired near elliott avenue which is part
of an area known as george floyd square
a short time later a person showed up at
abbott northwestern hospital suffering
from a non-life-threatening gunshot
wound according to authorities
like the and by the way this is not
uncommon march
28th new york times the sacred
intersection sacred
right sacred it's now a holy site it's a
site of pilgrimage and ritual
sacred intersection the the the secular
religion
that is leftism requires martyrs and it
requires
acts of fealty and it requires acts of
faith and those acts of fealty and faith
include
the the sainting of victims in american
society and the blaming of the entire
system at large
sacra i mean you saw this with nancy
pelosi literally thanking george floyd
for dying
after the convention of derrick shoven
which is an unbelievable thing i mean
that
that equivalent to to sort of the
christian thought
that jesus died for your sins nancy
pelosi suggested that george floyd died
for america since then thanked him for
his death i mean this sort of thinking
is so perverse in the united states it's
it's beyond reckoning
the new york times says the sacred
intersection where george floyd died
beneath the neva police officer has seen
such an increase in violence that food
delivery drivers are afraid to venture
there there have been gun battles with
bloodied shooting victims dragged to
ambulances because of barricades keeping
the police and emergency vehicles away
residents all over town still complain
of officers using excessive force
and officers accuse some community
members of antagonizing them like in a
recent dispute over our homeless
encampment that erupted into a melee
with punches and pepper spray ten months
ago minneapolis and the country seemed
to coalesce around the belief that
policing
needed an overhaul now with the murder
trial of the officer who nelson floyd's
next scheduled to begin on monday
remember this is written a couple of
months ago the struggle over what to
overhaul
has left minneapolis at war with itself
the the square itself has turned into a
powder keg
according to the new york times hone in
on the four neighborhoods surrounding
the george floyd square
the story is bleak and deadly in those
areas powderhorn park central bryant and
bancroft
violent crime shot up by 66 last year
according to stats from the police
department
this year so far little has changed the
area has become something of an
autonomous zone with barriers and signs
calling it the free state of george
floyd well this is the free state of
george floyd
it looks a lot more like a place for
gang warfare
it looks like it looks like a hellscape
if this is the free state of george
floyd people are literally firing shots
at george floyd's memorial on the
one-year commemoration of his death
and this is the black lives matter
movement that was supposed to make
america much much better
okay again show me the evidence that
america has gotten better in some way
over the course of the last year
and when you say awareness has been
raised awareness of what exactly
really truly awareness of what that some
police officers
have committed acts of brutality i think
we all acknowledge this
what the media really want you to be
aware of is a false story about what the
united states is
and what the united states should be
when they say that america has gotten
better they don't mean
that conditions on the ground have
gotten better for anybody they don't
care that conditions have gotten
significantly worse for black americans
on the ground in america's major cities
in the highest crime areas they don't
care about that
what they mean when they say that
america has gotten better is they mean
it is easier for them
to foment an agenda that tears down
america's institutions
they mean that they believe that they
have made political headway in tearing
away
the systems of the united states and
constitutional
systems and baseline individual
liberties
things like due process and equality of
rights before law
when they say things have gotten better
what they mean is that they've been able
to forward their agenda
not that things have actually gotten
better for black americans because they
pretty obviously and statistically have
not
okay in just one second we're gonna get
to exactly what i mean and
again they're using this to foment
exactly right it's george it's the
anniversary of george floyd's
death and therefore you can't do
anything the left doesn't want you to do
today right it's a magic day
perfect example piece by dana milbank in
the washington post
republicans spent the anniversary of
george floyd's murder trying to vote
down
a black woman oh what now
so the idea here is that because george
floyd was murdered by a police officer
we are not allowed to vote against any
black person for a government office
no matter how ridiculously unqualified
like kristen clarke
i mean this is insane here's dana
milbank from the washington post
republicans
chose a special way of observing the
anniversary of george floyd's murder
they tried to vote down a highly
qualified black woman who has been
nominated to run the justice
department's civil rights division
from i can't breathe to i won't confirm
so he is now equating
the death of george floyd to a
government nominee by the biden
administration who not only is utterly
unqualified
but is a garbage nominee being voted
against by republicans these are the
same thing if you vote against a black
person
for a high position of power in the
united states government because her
qualifications are crap
then according to dana milbank this is
the equivalent of you kneeling on the
neck of a black person until they die
according to the washington post
president biden had set a deadline of
tuesday for congress to enact
legislation to counter police brutality
but while the house passed the georgia
floyd justice and policing act almost
three months ago
republican objections have bottled up
negotiations in the senate
chuck senate majority leader chuck
schumer's office said the timing of
tuesday's vote was a coincidence
still democrats were happy to point out
the convergence it wasn't a coincidence
i'm sure the floyd murder by a
minneapolis police officer set off a
fight for justice schumer said on the
senate floor and here in the senate
we will continue that fight when we vote
to confirm the first black woman ever to
lead the justice department's civil
rights division
senator dick durbin of illinois majority
whip also cited the floyd anniversary
and urging his colleagues to consider
the historic importance of this moment
again
this is now a club it's a political club
it's not about making life better for
black people it's a political club for
democrats period
which is why democrats went so soft on
the blm writers
because these were just people of course
who were overzealous and simply too
committed
and maybe a little too enraged but they
had the right idea and that idea was to
create running room
for democrats to push whatever agenda
items they wish to pursue
but according to dana milbank it's just
racism republicans considered and then
all but once using collins maine
voted not even to allow clark a
confirmation vote and when that failed
voted by an identical tally against
confirming clark
not a single republican spoke against
clark on the floor tuesday not even when
zurban yielded them
for a final summation
okay so what exactly is the um what
exactly
are kristin clark's qualifications david
harsanya has written about this
repeatedly for national review
let me explain why kristin clarke did
not deserve a vote
is david harsanyi kristin clark joe
biden's nominee for assistant attorney
general of the united states once
promoted racist pseudoscientific
quackery
arguing that the human brain was
structured in a way that makes black
people superior to white people and that
human mental processes in the brain
have chemicals that imbue one race with
superior physical and mental abilities
and spiritual abilities rather than
owning up to a youthful relationship
with radicalism
clark who made these comments in the
harvard crimson as a 19 year old claims
her racist diatribe was merely a parody
mocking the controversial book the bell
curve what i was seeking to do is hold
up a mirror she says
purely by chance clark also happened to
invite a holocaust denying fraud named
anthony martin then a professor at
wellesley college whose primary assigned
textbook was called the secret
relationship between blacks and jews
which blame jews for the slave trade and
who wrote the jewish onslaught
published by louis farrakhan she invited
that guy to speak at harvard
at the same time clark was writing about
black supremacy she was calling martin
an intelligent well-versed black
intellectual who bases in
his information on indisputable fact
then last year she wrote a piece for
newsweek titled i prosecuted police
killings
defund the police but be strategic
again not only that she suggested that
jesse smilet
when when the police asked for jesse
smallett's phone
and asked for evidence that they were
being racist okay this person is not
qualified
to lead the the civil rights division of
the doj
but according to the media remember
because of the racial reckoning to vote
against her would be an act of racism
and this is really why people on the
left think that the world's gotten
better over the course of last year when
by all available evidence for black
americans it has not the answer is
because
they think that the the agenda that they
are pushing is going to be fomented
by the black lives matter movement even
if it means that more black people are
going to die in cities and even if it
means that education gets worse
and even if it means that racial
polarization gets worse none of that
matters to them it's
all about the agenda agenda agenda
that's all that matters to them
which is why they've been using this
quote unquote racial reckoning to push
forward things like the 1619 project
it's why they've been using this
quote-unquote racial reckoning to push
for a critical race
theory in schools and the media are
fully invested in this the reason the
media are in full celebration mode one
year after george floyd's death when
things have gotten markedly worse for
black americans living in high crime
areas
is because they believe that they have
found the lever for change
so politico for example let me listen to
the way that the media
skews stories political has reported
today about
oklahoma passing a bill that bans
critical race theory teaching in schools
okay here's how they here's how they
headline this anti-racism teaching ban
divides oklahoma a head of tulsa
massacre centennial
and so you just read that headline what
you would assume is a bunch of racists
in oklahoma
want to make sure that no one ever
learns about racism in oklahoma
right about the same time as the 100
year anniversary
of the tulsa oklahoma massacre okay
that's not what's going on
at all oklahoma just pushed forward a
bill that said
that you can't educate kids to feel
discomfort guilt anguish or any other
form
of psychological distress solely due to
race or gender
that doesn't mean you can't teach
american history it means you're not
allowed to say that kids are
beneficiaries of white supremacy and
therefore
are should feel guilty about their own
race because that's what critical race
theory effectively argues is that all
white people no matter who you are
are beneficiaries of evil systems in the
united states and therefore ought to
feel guilty about their race
that is a main it is a hallmark of
critical race theory which of course
argues that racism is not abnormal it's
not abnormality it is natural
it is ingrained in white populations and
that every white person
is a secret both psychological and
material beneficiary
of white privilege but according to
politico it's very bad to say this
democratic state senator kevin matthews
said quote the biggest problem is we
would pass legislation that says we
wouldn't be able to teach diversity
equity and inclusion in schools
it generally says something like that no
that's not what it says what it says is
that you are not allowed to teach
racial discrimination on the basis of
race
as educators have sought to explore u.s
history with lessons increasingly
informed by slavery dred scott and jim
crow
particularly after george floyd's
killing by police last year there is the
there's the obligatory political
reference
conservatives have moved to block
political interpretations of critical
race theory from classrooms
many republicans across the country in
washington have blasted it as racist
liberal indoctrination well that's
because that is what it
is and nonetheless politico says the
reason they're doing this is because of
the tulsa
race massacre of course that's not true
it takes a long time for these
legislative proposals to finally
reach the light of day but the goal here
is that if you can link this to george
floyd which everybody agrees is bad
then that means that you're racist to
oppose what democrats want to do
this is why you see ta-nehisi coates for
example suggesting that it is racism and
ta-nehisi coates is one of the great
race grifters in american life
he is a he's a purple writer who is
extremely vague in his thinking
which is why he can never peg down
exactly what it is that he is saying
and instead reverts to very
very evocative phraseology and things
like
the the impact on black bodies which he
uses this phraseology he uses frequently
or when he talks about
the systemic racism that has wrought its
its legacy
on black americans ta-nehisi quotes his
favorite
routine in his writing is that he takes
a bad thing that happened in 1880 and
then he
fast forwards directly to 2021 and says
that nothing has changed which of course
is a lie
in any case here's todd ohasico's
defending critical race theory on the
basis that somehow this is going to make
the country a better place
no matter how discomforting an idea is
no matter how
you know an idea makes you feel or
whatever
when you're uh when you see the state
using policy to remove those notions
from the public square
um you you've got a problem of a
different order again i just want to be
really really clear you don't have to
agree with nicole
you don't agree with me you don't have
to agree with with anybody but when you
see the president of the united states
directing an executive order uh towards
a journalistic project you should be
afraid
okay directing an executive order to a
journalistic project no he put together
an executive order putting together what
he called the 1776 commission he's
talking about trump there the 1776
commission
thoroughly debunks the 1619 project
which is garbage pseudo history
the 1619 project is filled with lies and
proverications as
everyone who has studied it knows anyone
who has spent any amount of time knows
that it is filled with conjecture
and foolishness and none of that is
tonight to deny the evils of slavery
or the impact that history has on the
present the 1619 project however
is rife with historical inaccuracy and
full-scale lies about the founding of
the united states and american ideals
but to oppose that apparently means that
you are in league with george floyd's
murderers or something
that is why the left believes that
things have gotten better over the past
year when there is no evidence that
year
by the way this is being crammed down on
your kids according to daily wire an
oregon school board updated a policy to
mandate that each classroom in the
school district display a black lives
matter and progressive pride flag or
poster
on may 6 the gresham barlow school board
and gresham oregon updated the
district's flag displays and salutes
policy to reflect the progressive values
of the board
the proposal would require the school
board to provide an american flag
pride flag and blm flag for each
classroom because if we are talking
about messages
that every american has to be forced to
embrace we are now talking about the
radical lgbtq plus agenda
the blm agenda and the american flag are
all interchangeable according to the
left which is complete crap
considering that the documents of the
constitution of the united states and
the declaration of independence
are market rebukes to many elements of
that agenda
according to the policy the district
shall obtain and display a u.s flag a
progressive
pride flag or poster and a black lives
matter flag or poster of an appropriate
size for each classroom
okay this is with taxpayer dollars nuts
nuts apparently
other members of the school board
suggested that students recite
land acknowledgement once
a week and recite the black national
anthem as well all of this is divisive
it makes the country worse but of course
the goal is to divide the country
further so that you can then cram down a
policy
from above a policy that rectifies all
racial imbalances
it's just nasty nasty stuff here from
the
from the radical left again using
george's deaths
george floyd's death as an opportunity
not to make life better for americans
but to tear down institutions that by
the way have made black americans the
richest black people on the face of the
earth i mean in economic terms
there is no country in which black
americans are freer and there is no
country in which black americans are
richer that does not deny
the evil history of the united states
with regard to slavery or jim crow
that is a recognition of facts on the
ground today there is in fact a giant
and thriving black middle class in the
country i know the media want you to
believe
that the only black people in america
are people who are either extremely
wealthy or
extremely poor but that is not true in
the slightest and it's a slander
on the very many black americans who
have made tremendous
economic progress in the united states
it's also slander on the system which
allows people to make economic progress
regardless of race
in fact if race were the great indicator
here then there would be no reason
why nigerian americans for example are
better educated than the general
population have a higher household
income
in any case the the media continue to
push the idea that things gotten better
over the past year because again
it's not about whether things got better
it's about whether they can push forward
the agenda they want to push forward
already in just a second
we'll get to more insane media
malfeasance because there's a headline
from the new york times that is just
beyond it's just beyond we'll get to
that in one second first
let's talk about the fact that if you
are using a free email service from a
big tech email provider
it's really not super free because
you're paying with your privacy
since those companies have access to
every email you send and receive big
tech can sell your data to the highest
bidder that's why i trust start mail to
secure my email
it makes me feel safe again start mail
keeps my email private which is super
important to me every email is encrypted
even if the recipient doesn't use
encryption
that means bigtech cannot read scan
analyze or sell my personal information
ever not even big brother can snoop
around your email start mail also
prevents government agencies from spying
on you
like in giant dragnet operations with
start mail deleted means deleted
when you delete an email it is gone
forever and start mail uses their
servers not big tech servers which means
they cannot be put out of business and
they are backed by the most stringent
privacy laws in the world so i mean this
is a great way of protecting your
personal privacy again a lot of people
are using gmail because it's free and
because convenient
yeah but the reason it's free is because
they're monetizing your data and again
you don't want those people having your
data i mean you're putting your most
private stuff
in your emails i don't trust big tech
you shouldn't either start securing your
email privacy with start mail today
sign up today you'll get fifty percent
off your first year go to startmail.com
that's start mail with a t s t a rt
mail.com slash ben for 50 off your very
first year is super easy to get started
the email works
beautifully start mail.com go check them
out right now
start mail.com alright we're gonna get
some more
in just one second first after a year of
lockdown
prices across the country are rising in
tandem leftist insanity you're probably
ready to hear some voices of reason make
sense of it so
tonight throw out that mask and join me
jeremy boring michael knows matt walsh
and andrew clavin for another cigar and
sanity packed episode of
backstage it streams tonight at seven
o'clock p.m eastern 6 p.m central on
dailywire.com and
on our youtube channel daily wire also
if you've ever imagined touring the
delaware headquarters
sitting front row at a live candidate
show hanging out with candace owens
herself
today could be your lucky day when you
sign up as a daily wire member with code
vip
you'll get 20 off your new membership
and you'll be automatically entered for
a chance to win a trip to daily wire
studios to see candace live i get this
question all the time people are
emailing me how do i go see candace live
here's how not only will you be meeting
candace you'll get an inside look at her
studio our office front row seats to
watch her take down leftist live
and in action on her talk show candace
so this is really happening don't sleep
on it go enter to win
a candace at vip pass right now at
dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 20 off
again that is dailywire.com
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
alrighty so the media as always they
have one agenda and that is to push
whatever the democratic party wants this
headline from the new york times is just
this is a stellar headline from the new
york times really full credits in the
new york times four points
here is the headline democrats once
outraged
take a quieter approach to migrant
children yeah that's a real headline
from the new york times
so you may have been wondering you
american citizen why it was that aoc was
going down to the border
and putting on a spontaneous white
outfit and standing spontaneously in
front of a chain-link fence
spontaneously in front of a giant empty
plaza
spontaneously in front of a child
holding facility
and why a photographer was spontaneously
there taking spontaneous pictures of aoc
spontaneously crying spontaneously while
looking spontaneously into camera
you may have been wondering why she was
doing that but she's got
nothing to say like she's not down at
the border right now and there's a
multiple of the number of children being
held in detention facilities by the
biden administration amidst a coveted
pandemic that is still hitting
all the people who are migrating over
the border you may have wondered well
the
new york times has your answer they're
just taking a quieter approach you see
they're still mad use it but they're
quieter about it they're just quieter
now why are they quieter who knows who
knows could be
maybe they may have got linear and titus
you never know
maybe it's just that their hands were
paralyzed they couldn't type or
something but you just don't know but
they're quieter
according to eileen sullivan at the new
york times house democrats who led an
angry charge against the trump
administration's treatment of migrant
children
have taken a much quieter tax since
concerns began emerging about conditions
at some of the emergency shelters set up
by the biden administration to deal with
minors at the southern border
where once only twitter assaults and
dressings down at house hearings would
suffice
democratic lawmakers are voicing worries
privately to administration officials
and the small staff
at dhhs which oversees the care if
problems persist the lawmakers say
they call again democrats say the
contrast is for good reason
former president donald j trump's
immigration policies were deliberately
cruel
devised as a deterrent to would-be
migrants while the biden administration
is trying hard to deal with a bad hand
oh is that why oh it's because you like
the people in the white house i mean we
can boil that one down right that's what
they mean
we like the people in the white house
therefore they're good people we don't
have to yell at them we just address it
we do a little back massage and maybe
we try and give joe a can of insure and
maybe he'll do what we want by the way
number of migrant children has not
decreased since joe biden took office
that was in january
it is now nearly the end of may
according to joaquin castro democrat of
texas the difference
is you have an administration who wants
to solve a lot of these challenges and
their heart
isn't a much oh their hearts it's in a
better place it's like in a jar on the
shelf their heart is in a better place
representative veronica escobar democrat
of texas said she has so far been
impressed with the administration
officials working on the issue
they have a solid vision and a heart of
gold they're with a heart of gold
and they seem to want to do the right
thing which is different from what i
experienced during the trump
administration said escobar during the
trump administration was all excuses or
sorry this is the way it is oh so
oh i see i see what's happening here
so now they just went quiet but the good
you know what they went quiet for a
reason it's because democrats have a
heart of gold
by the way what is the bible
administration actually doing they're
incentivizing massive illegal
immigration across the border today
washington post at the detention centers
in county jails that the trump
administration once filled with
immigrants facing deportations
thousands of beds are now empty the
immigration and customs enforcement
officers that president donald trump
lavished with praise have far less to do
on the streets of the u.s these days
under the new biden administration rules
curtailing immigration enforcement
ice carried out fewer than 3 000
deportations last month the lowest
levels on record
the agencies 6 000 officers currently
average one arrest
every two months ice under president
biden is an agency on probation
the new administration has rejected
calls from some democrats to eliminate
the agency but biden has placed ice
deportation officers on a leash so tight
some say their work is being
functionally abolished immigration
advocacy groups and lawyers who wield
significant influence in the biden white
house
are pushing to eliminate more detention
facilities and reduce deportations even
further despite a 20-year high in legal
border crossings
so you know why democrats aren't worried
about all these children being held in
migrant facilities because they're very
much in favor of the open border policy
being pursued by the biden
administration
once the administration says to ice you
cannot deport people who are crossing
the border illegally
they're de facto issuing a come on in
announcement free cupcakes
cross the border and then we're all
supposed to be surprised
when children swamped the border why
should we be surprised about that you
have fully incentivized this just like
defund the police causes crime
we will not deport anyone causes illegal
immigration
democrats know this and they don't care
they're happy about it
that's why they're quote-unquote quieter
because they like the broader region
they don't care that kids are being held
in inhumane conditions on the border
because the broader agenda which is to
get more illegal immigrants into the
country is something the democrats
support
as always real-time suffering means
nothing to democrats it's a long-term
utopian vision that means everything
to democrats the biden administration is
preparing to release its first
department of homeland security budget
request this week immigrant advocates
want deep cuts to ice
deep cuts to ice in the middle of a vast
upswell in illegal immigration cut the
agency responsible for deportations
dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas
announced plans last week to shut her
two ice detention centers
but he says he wants to reorient ice not
shrink it he said i really am focused on
it becoming a premier national security
and law enforcement agency
i really want to elevate all of the
other work ice does and also ensure that
its civil immigration work is well
focused
in the service of the national security
and public safety mission so what
exactly does that mean
under biden's new rules deportation
officers must seek written authorization
from senior level supervisors
to arrest anyone who is not a recent
border crosser
a national security threat or an
aggravated felon
okay so if you've committed a
misdemeanor you're fine
if you commit a felony but you're not
considered an aggravated felon you're
still fine
so long as you came here a little while
ago before placing a detainer on an
immigrant
in a jail or a prison so these are
people who have already been arrested
essentially asking another law
enforcement agency to hold that person
until ice can assume custody officers
must also seek approval from one of the
agency's
most senior regional directors so it
used to be that automatically if
somebody was arrested and they were an
illegal immigrant
ice would put an automatic detainer
request in with local law enforcement to
say we can deport these people as
opposed to keeping them in american
jails
now biden wants you to have to go to
your supervisor to allow this which
effectively means a lot of people who
are
felons people who have committed crimes
in the united states will not be
deported
ice officials frustrated with the
changes describe a workplace environment
where officers spend time doing
paperwork
idling or working out more fearful of
facing reprimand for making an arrest
and not making one so basically they're
doing twice what they have done to the
cops and the predictable result
is more crime this is not a shock in any
way shape or form but don't worry things
are getting better guys according to the
new york times democrats are quiet
because
everybody in the administration has a
heart of gold so
much goldenheartedness going on by the
way a little bit of disparate treatment
of crime
you notice there's a big story out right
now about how a grand jury has convened
in new york with regard to president
trump and how latisha james the attorney
general of the state of new york
came into office pledging to go after
trump she didn't say what crime he'd
committed but she was pledged to go
after
him acknowledge basically admitting that
there was political prosecution from the
very beginning
the media are over the moon about law
enforcement with regard to trump
when we don't even know what crimes he
supposedly has committed here but when
it comes to actual people committing
actual crimes the answer is defund the
police
make sure that kristen clarke who's a
radical with regards to the cops
is in charge of investigating the police
and ensuring civil rights
at the doj and defund ice
remember that time when this is supposed
to be a moderate administration yeah i
don't either
because it was never going to be a
moderate administration that was always
a lie that people
were just telling you end of story it
was all about that
and the media are playing the game man
whatever they can do to distract
from the failures of this administration
from the correct multiple
there are multiple crises they are
administration created there is a crime
crisis it is created by this
administration
and by the democrats and by the media
there is a racial polarization crisis in
the country fomented by the media
there's an illegal immigration crisis
fomented by the media
fomented by this administration but you
know it is one year anniversary of
george floyd so i guess we're not
supposed to talk
about any of that all right meanwhile
when we speak of media
misdirection gotta talk a little bit
about marjorie taylor green
so marjorie taylor green made a couple
of statements over the past
48 hours so one of them was a statement
on twitter
and the other one of them was a
statement that she made on
david brody's show on real america's
voice i commented yesterday on the radio
show about the real america's voice
statement her
tweet on twitter was basically just
doubling down on those particular
comments
okay so here was marjorie taylor green
on david brody's show yesterday
making a holocaust comparison and
reference with regard to masking that
makes no sense and it's kind of insane
this woman is mentally ill you know we
can look back in a time in history
where people were told to wear a gold
star and they were definitely
treated like second class citizens so
much so
that they were put in trains and taken
to gas chambers
in nazi germany and this is exactly the
type of abuse that nancy pelosi is
talking about
okay uh no that's not precisely the kind
of stuff that nancy pelosi is talking
about as i noted
yesterday and then of course she doubled
down on this on twitter because
everybody doubles down on everything on
twitter this is the new strategy
on twitter right she suggested on
twitter
that basically the the same thing
that the that that vaccine passports are
equivalent to
the the gold star it's a yellow star
the the but she called it the gold star
and that this is like what
nazis did right and so i talked about
this on twitter i said this is a bad
idea right
this is that this is crazy what she's
saying right here
and naturally the republican party came
out and they said this is crazy talk
right i mean comparing mass mandates
to the holocaust or suggesting that that
nancy pelosi's house policy on masking
on the floor is equivalent to
sending jews on trains to gas chambers
or it's leading to sending jews on
trains to gas chambers
in any that it's it's wild stuff and
margery taylor green says wild stuff
right
i've said before when she deserves
praise she deserves praise there have
been times where i praised her on this
show
she's a broken clock who's write twice a
day and when she's right she's right
when she's wrong she's wrong this is one
where she's wrong mitch mcconnell kind
of slapped around it yesterday here was
the senate minority leader saying that
this sort of language was inappropriate
and then i'll talk about the
ramifications for broader american
politics because this is where things
get kind of interesting
well she doesn't serve in the senate but
this is one of a frequent outbursts
that are absolutely outrageous and
reprehensible but any punishment i
assume would have to be
administered by the house okay so first
of all
the voters can administer whatever
punishment to marge or taylor green they
wish to do she's an elected official
they can do that
if they want second of all if we're
talking about
holocaust comparisons that are bad these
of course are not restricted to mars
retailer greens democrats called trump
hitler for four years the number of
holocaust references being put forward
by democrats in the last four years
there's a plethora of them i've
condemned a lot of them i've talked
about a lot of them
okay and then beyond that put aside the
holocaust references democrats including
the president of the united states
suggested for example that georgia
voting law was jim crow
which is again an overt historical lie
that demeans jim crow
and and presents jim crow as something
that apparently is not that serious if
it's just like the georgia voting law
it's ridiculous right it downplays
jim crow so these sorts of bad
historical comparisons happen all the
time for members of congress and they
suck they're bad but
let's be real about this the reason that
the media are paying outsized attention
to marjory taylor green's comments is
because they don't want to talk about
the overt anti-semitism of the
democratic party at this point
that is why they are doing this marjorie
taylor green's comments on masking
and the holocaust are going to get
precisely zero jews beaten in the
streets of new york
ilhan omar's comments and aoc's comments
and ayanna presley's comments
and the comments of members of the media
who are overtly pushing pro hamas
talking points
that does get jews beaten in the streets
of new york it does get jews threatened
on the streets of miami it does get a
rabbi
in my community threatened by a guy
wearing a hamas headband
okay so but the media are it's amazing
to watch the media jump on the margery
taylor green thing because she provided
them the opening right
she said this and so they're like ah we
can condemn anti-semitism first of all
i'm not sure that her comment
this one right the jew laser thing is is
anti-semite is anti-semitic conspiracy
theory
bad holocaust comparisons are absurd and
deranged but they are not
de facto anti-semitic right people make
bad historical comparisons all the time
it happens routinely but the reason the
media are focusing on this is that they
can say that they don't like
anti-semitism while completely letting
the squad off scot-free
the squad has participated in blood
libels here they've suggested that
israel is targeting palestinian children
that is a lie it is an overt
disgusting lie it is a blood libel
against the jewish state
they've suggested that because israel
has an imbalance in military power
israel's citizens should be living under
the threat of random rocket fire
they've suggested sympathy for a hamas
terror group that explicitly calls for
the abolition of the state of israel
and running the jews into the sea okay
this is what the democrats have done
and the democrats will not condemn the
other democrats for doing this they'll
condem anti-semitism more broadly some
maybe many democrats were like well we
condem anti-semitism and also
islamophobia
also there's no uptick in islamophobic
attacks in the united states
none there's no data to suggest that but
the reason that the democrats keep
pairing anti-semitism with islamophobia
is to justify the anti-semitism right
their claim is that if you are
pro-israel
this means that you are by nature
islamophobic and therefore if you're
islamophobic an attack on you is really
not anti-semitism
it's really just a form of defending
muslims and that is the perverse logic
that is being
put forward by democrats on the radical
left today the media refused to pay
attention to this
the new york times as far as i'm aware
has run precisely zero stories on the
radical uptick in anti-semitism in their
news section
in the united states instead they
printed literally today the new york
times
a map of israel that is so
factually incorrect that when msnbc put
it out there in 2015 the same map
they had to apologize for saying it was
factually incorrect
that was a map that showed all of israel
as palestine and then it's shrinking
down
palestine into these little dots it's
just a it's a lie it's not true the new
york times pressed it forward anyway
they they're they're printing pieces by
actual spokespeople for terrorist
organizations like the palestine
liberation organization
the media have nothing to say about this
because the media are in favor of it
okay so let me give you an example last
night
dana bash and wolf blitzer did a full
segment on marjory taylor green's
comments which were condemned by the way
by kevin mccarthy their
the house minority leader and by the
senate minority leader i've yet to see a
single democrat come out and actually
condemn by name ilhan omar and her
radically anticipated comments were
recited to leave and heretically
anticipated comments
or the apartheid state nonsense of
ayanna presley
not a single democrat not a single major
democrat but here dana bash and wolf
blitz are getting very teary eyed and
emotional over marjorie taylor green's
comments meanwhile
it's honest to god it's absurd it's
ridiculous on the highest level
okay i also don't think that margery
taylor green's comments are good i also
don't like those comments i think that
they are
ill-advised i think that they are
bizarre i think they're crazy
i don't think that they are fomenting
anti-semitism in the united
states that results in jews being beaten
on the streets of new york i know jews
who are being beaten on the streets of
new york today
they are being beaten by pro-palestinian
activists who believe the same things
the editorial board of the new york
times believes apparently but cnn
they're very upset about what they
perceive to be
slight treatment of anti-semitism when
it's marge retailer
again it ain't masking advocate
anti-masking advocates who are beating
jews today but here's what blitz are
getting very teary-eyed
while simultaneously providing coverage
for a network that does cover for hamas
all the damn time
after the third time she was given a
chance
to either recant or retract or clarify
she tripled down on these repulsive
comments wolf
yeah i mean it's really sick when you
think about it for you and me
it's not just political it's not just
the story we're covering this is a very
personal issue given the fact that both
of us we lost
family during the holocaust being
gassed which is what my
great-grandparents were is a whole
different thing and to compare that to
the notion of public health uh and
wearing a mask
is just beyond the pale okay so that
they're very very upset about what
margaret taylor how about how about what
hamas says
seriously wolf blitzer covers this
conflict regularly on his program does
he ever talk about how upset he is that
he had
you know relatives who died in the
holocaust and his parents were holocaust
survivors and
does he talk about the fact that hamas
explicitly calls for genocide against
jews
does he does he talk about that and how
upsetting that must be as the child of
holocaust does he ever talk
about democratic party members providing
de facto support for hamas
literally trying to cut off funding for
iron dome in the middle
of the war does he talk about people in
the democratic party overtly lying
about what the jews are doing in israel
about how the jews are are participating
in an apartheid state and attempting to
target palestinian church no of course
not
has nothing to say about that because
the routine is this when it comes to the
media first priority protect the
democratic party so anti-semitism is
only worth noting
even if it isn't even it's just crazy
and not anti-semitic
the taking the holocaust lightly is
worthy of note
when it is marjorie taylor green but
when it is entire marches taking place
in the streets across the world
in which israel is being compared to
hitler
nothing nada then the media are
completely silent
so are they really concerned about
anti-semitism not in the slightest
they are only concerned about
misdirecting away from the people they
want to protect
namely anti-semites in the democratic
party are perfectly fine with watching
the state of israel be wiped off the map
i mean they're members of congress right
now in the democratic party who call the
establishment of the state of israel
anoka right they disaster
that's about the establishment of the
state of israel it's it's truly
an amazing amazing site and so uh they
have no credibility to speak on these
issues whatsoever none their agenda is
perfectly clear all the way through two
things as always can be true at once
i can say that i don't like margery
taylor green's comments i can say that i
think that they are
demented crazy and i can also say that
the true threat to america's
jews is not coming from archery taylor
green the true threat to america's jews
based on stats based on evidence based
on what's going on
today our anti-semites who agree with
the democratic party's
radical left position on israel
being fomented by members of the media
who overtly push propaganda on behalf of
genocidal anti-jewish terrorists
alrighty well we will be back here later
today with an additional hour of content
in the meantime go check out the michael
moell show where he discusses george
will's
kind of crazy comments from the other
day comparing 1 6 to 9 11 he says we
should remember
january 6 like 9 11 which is nuts
you can hear more details about this
story over on michael's show that is
available right now i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
para and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
democrats take a break from calling us
nazis to complain that a republican
called them nazis
conservatives try to win back the
country one school board at a time
and john cena grovels to the chicons
check it out
on the michael knoll show